hello and welcome to this week's game
fish puppy it is okay so what am I
playing here I've been experimenting
with this Bishop c5 setups and probably
will get that here as well no I won't
III as a a good alternative for white
for g3 I mean yeah this is what is
normally plate yeah there's some stuff
with 95 that could happen I think they
quite often just take him and don't wait
until the night move to the five might
happen yeah here at least I've got very
um very quick development that I will go
d5 and open the position for my for my
pieces yep let's go d 5 you will
probably take so what's the deal here
Bishop open g4 certainly possible hmm i
wonder i would also somehow would love
to make Bishop f5 work but II force is
just a big Fork you know I don't have
any technical justification for that so
I'm just going to develop
yeah well here I might have an
opportunity I'm not sure about the
quality of it but now i'm going to try
on Bishop cakes i can take on before for
a couple of points this could be
interesting I'm not sure about it but
let's see if he takes with the bishop
Knight takes pawn takes Knight takes no
it seems that he was a little bit afraid
down okay now i'm going to push a fat
for trying to fight for the default
square the idea is to make this III pawn
move maybe you will go be five now and
push my night back you know you won't ok
I'll go away for here that's that's
that's a given I think you should go be
five maybe I should should have played a
six actually hmm yeah I should have
played 86 after b5 I probably have to go
all the way back to be eight not a big
issue but hmm I probably should have
played a six he had promised in general
he would like to play but should be too
but that's not possible I see three
years so much under under under pressure
so yeah I wonder just a 6 i'm going to
do this i'm just i think i should have
done that William it's not easy for him
now to play this position
here's a hard time to move any of his
Center pawns and it's not clear what is
king is going to do yeah yeah this is
not working i think you j 5 ok maybe he
has got Quincy five here no I think I
can take before I guess no it's not
application
yet Quincy five I maybe I'll just move
the Queen ho take a three Jack don't
think i might add so much I mean he
didn't blunder that he gave this pawn
willingly okay check here and then maybe
night to be for Jack don't think I need
to trade him okay oh he can track my
night before this night to be four or
the other night I'm taking them maybe is
that making any sense probably not Jack
so let's jump to before
so I was thinking maybe c5
pawn takes Knight cheeks not sure a
couple of couple of interesting options
here but I think I'll go for that he
were very likely I shouldn't pre-move
knight c6 white has to take on personal
basically if he allows b6 my position
will be I think too strong then he has a
hard time to move anything actually I
think he should take and play rook c1 or
something like that yeah you know idea
was like an ID to before and pile up on
d3 it's not so easy to win this position
um I think because his king is um
somewhat active and maybe he has some
ideas their King a4 to be five or
something I don't think that works but
yeah again the problem is that him his
bishops are passive hmm ok so just
double up here on the deep on you know
there's no particular threat down like
Luke a five or so yeah I think t3 is
just dropping you never can take care
for the whole time because of 94
check hmm okay white resigns yes sir
checkmate funky made um yeah I think I'm
I think you should probably just play
the position on with the with Bishop
takes let's see let's see I went Bishop
g4 I should be 2 r.d aid so what is good
about my position is that I'm I'm very
fluently developing my pieces but white
has the bishop pair for long term play
okay could have also just castled for ya
and now I know I took it it castles the
save of course I mean he will have to do
it anyway and here maybe later before
and now I took and he didn't dare to
take with the bishop I'm not sure about
the merits of this this sacrifice on
before no the engine likes a delightful
black I wasn't sure I really wasn't sure
I would have played it but um what I saw
is that ok the Queen has to move now
that wasn't quite sure we have it let's
say here i saw that i can get to check
in and go a form and i thought this
should be should be all right i mean i
didn't really calculate ok bishop a
three for example i didn't see but Queen
age for might still be good because of
the maid threat on f2 and if he goes
back something like this is already
quite a nuisance now blacks winning
according to the comp mmm no it's not
it's not fun for white yeah maybe maybe
this some this means that well energy
takes also isn't great I mean what he
what he got in the game so probably
before isn't good than what he should
castle
I think here I'd rather be white in this
position but I'm a typical Bishop addict
it's not so easy to come up with a clear
plan in this position you don't really
have straightforward chances font King
for King side attack and yeah engine
wants to play like a six route d6 and
just be sold at him I think why does a
bit better him and okay then this is a
problem and now this position gets is
difficult I think I made a mistake here
with this move I should have played a
six first and later if I their form
which is the standard idea against the
structure yeah okay and you should go be
five I ignored this possibility again I
should play a a six and b5 now isn't
cleared or because I have to go on a
pretty awful square down now if or isn't
isn't that bad because now I'm I don't
control D for my night is pretty far
away here white is ok I should play a
six the whole time and now i got it in
finally and this is just a better
structure for black and white cannot
move any of his pawns the bishops stay
passive and I think long castles
probably didn't work due to a 525 is
still a playable move though this is
what he had to do I think as I said in
during the game I wanted to take and
like here and then I thought I'd move
the Queen but the computer wants to go
look to d6 okay intending to take
immediately that's probably our strong
move it also allows this kind of thing
like the 86 and it looks very strong
long castles isn't a good move check yet
he obliges
winning more or less or I could have
taken b5 didn't see that Jack Jack a
this position is also excellent and it's
an easy play now just piled up on this
pointer which I he blundered that one
but this is basically hopeless he will
lose t3 yet it's two points down for for
nothing Deb was very very close here
this is very interesting and he should
go um castles instead of before eyes
before gives black an opportunity to
explore it is better development this is
what black hats is quicker developed um
interesting interesting okay well thanks
for watching